the added cost for groceries and gas
forcing a lot of families to have to
make some pretty difficult decisions and
some are realizing they just simply
cannot afford to keep up with the cost
associated with caring for their pet
which leads to abandonment and
surrendering in fact a local rescue
group believes that's why two pit bulls
were left tied to trees over the weekend
victoria saha joining us now in studio
with more on this growing issue victoria
denise you just can't help but wonder
how someone could abandon their pets
like that but it's a sad reality that's
becoming all too common overwhelming our
shelters so far this month the animal
foundation has taken in at least 90
animals every day
abandonment is really never ever a
legitimate excuse or option kelly winder
runs rescue missions across the valley
to get pets off our streets over the
weekend he responded when these two pit
bulls were found tied up to trees
besides shock it's anger there was no
doubt in winder's mind the pit bulls
were abandoned it's an option for the
lazy uneducated
and
the people that are ignorant of the
resources out there the dogs were taken
to the animal foundation where over 1300
animals were brought in just in the
first two weeks of june this includes
strays confiscations and surrenders the
last time they had that many was in 2019
but in 2020 the number was drastically
low as a lot of people got a pet during
the pandemic we knew
a storm was coming and it's not going to
be an easy fix four-year-old mona lisa
was amongst their surrenders this month
we met her just as she got adopted on
monday inflation is hurting everybody
let's be honest
and it doesn't matter whether you have a
lot of money or a little bit of money
owner mikhail lerma wanted to take a
chance on mona lisa despite the rising
cost of necessities just because the
world's gonna have issues doesn't mean i
can't help a dog out no one knows why
mona lisa was surrendered but as she
drives away to her forever home there
are hundreds of animals waiting for the
same
outcome
the animal foundation says owners often
don't disclose why they're surrendering
a pet but if it is for financial issues
they have programs that will help feed
and take care of your pets needs and you
do not need to meet a certain income
bracket we do have that information up
on our website at eight news now dot com
as for those two pit bulls that were
abandoned winder says one of them was
microchipped but the owner has not come
forward brian victoria thank you for
that